making big-budget blockbuster movies is
a complicated and insanely expensive
endeavor and keeping the Hollywood
machine running as sometimes requires
lengthy contracts to ensure that the
famous faces are attract theater goers
keep making their magic on the big
screen but this means sometimes the
high-profile actors attached to these
projects are actually working against
their will
contractually obligated to take on a
role that rather not actors such as
Jennifer Garner and Elektra after the
financial success of 2003 s daredevil
attention turned to a spin-off a
focusing on Jennifer Garner's character
Elektra daredevil writer and director
Mark Steven Johnson discussed bringing
Kevin Smith on board to help with the
screenplay and garner gushed in
interviews about possible paths a
storyline could take in the sequel she
was already under contract to complete
unfortunately sometimes even the best
laid plans go south and 2005 Elektra
didn't live up to anyone's expectations
Johnson was replaced as a writer and
director the film bombed at the box
office and was panned by audiences and
critics and garner herself even told her
ex-boyfriend Michael Watson that the
movie was awful in an interview with Us
Weekly Vartan explained she had to do it
because of daredevil it was in her
contract Mike Myers and the Cat in the
Hat
following his first Austin Powers movie
Universal signed Mike Myers to appear in
what was to be a comedy based on his
Dita character from Saturday Night Live
he backed out of the part due to issues
with the screenplay which launched a
series of legal battles between the
studio and the star eventually the sides
reached an agreement one that obligated
Myers to play the title character in a
live-action adaptation of dr.seuss is
the Cat in the Hat
Maya's reportedly made no effort to play
nice while on the set his co-star Amy
hill revealed that he acted like a
hermit and a diva throughout the whole
production the end result was so
underwhelming that dr. Seuss's Widow
Audrey Geisel stated in 2004 that she'd
never allow Hollywood to make another
live-action adaptation of one of his
books again Jessica Alba in Fantastic
Four rise of the Silver Surfer when you
agree to play a major character in
here a movie you'd better be prepared to
play that same role again in the future
even if the movie is a flop that was the
case for Jessica Alba who played
fantastic four team members Sue Storm in
the 2005 Fantastic Four movie because of
her three movie contract Alba was
obligated to return for the 2007 sequel
rise of the Silver Surfer an experience
she hated so much that she actually
considered quitting acting for good
Daniel Craig in Skyfall Inspector he's
been enormous ly successful in his role
as British spy James Bond but Daniel
Craig has always been brutally honest
about why he hates playing the character
and why he keeps doing it after the
release of Skyfall in 2012
Craig admitted that he was never keen on
becoming Bond in the first place saying
I've been trying to get out of this from
the very moment I got into it during the
2015 promotional tour for Spectre Craig
turned the bond hatred up a notch
responding to the prospect of more
sequels by saying he'd rather slash his
wrists than appear in another Bond film
and the saying if he did it would just
be for the money in July 2017
The Mirror reported that Craig will
indeed cash in and stay on to play bonds
for the fifth time
despite his well-publicized sustain for
the part Roy Scheider in Jaws 2 he rose
to worldwide fame with his role as
police chief Martin Brody in 1975's Jaws
but Roy Scheider wasn't particularly
excited to reprise his role in the 1978
sequel so why was he the only member of
the original cast to come back for the
second jaws film simple
he was contractually obliged telling
everybody at this table that's a shark
and I know what a shark looks like
because I've seen one up close and you
better do something about this one
because I don't China had signed the
multiple movie contract with Universal
Studios and that they had originally
cast him as the lead in 1978 the deer
hunter unhappy with the script he
dropped out of the film and was replaced
by Robert DeNiro but because of that
contract Universal was able to force
Scheider to reprise his role as chief
Brody in Jaws to Marlon Brando in
Desiree you would think Hollywood legend
Marlon Brando always got a say in which
movies he made but even Brando had to
deal with contractual obligations
most infamously when as a result of a
lawsuit filed by a producer he was
forced to appear as Napoleon in 1950
force Desiree but Brando didn't take it
lying down according to one biography he
made a point of forgetting his lines or
reciting them with a nasal pseudo
British intonation and creating havoc
between takes
including squirting extras with a fire
hose according to Brando's co-star the
late teen Simmons upon the film's
release Brando was amazed at the movie
success which included two Oscar
nominations one for art direction and
the other for design had a Brando put
some effort into his role he probably
could have garnered a nomination for
himself I could have been a contender I
could have been somebody thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]